hey y'all movie retrospective time yeah
night it Return of the Living Dead right
yeah yeah this is one I've been this is
another one that's been on my list since
like the beginning way back when I first
made the list and this is one that's
been requested like a whole bunch of
time yeah we grew up with this always
seen it a million times
yes this came out in 1985 a horror
comedy directed by Dan O'Bannon who was
one of the writers on the original alien
so there's that I think he was one of
the co writers on life force as well but
um
yes of the thing what happened with this
movie is that even though it's called
Return of the Living Dead and it does
reference George Romero's Night of the
Living Dead it's actually not in the
same timeline but I really actually kind
of like the way that they did this what
ended up happening behind the scenes
right was that George Romero and this
dude named John Russo they had worked
together to make Night of the Living
Dead and after they kind of like went
their separate ways or whatever John
Russo wrote a novel called Return of the
Living Dead which was kind of supposed
to be like continuing the story and he
made he like adapted a screenplay from
that book now initially what they were
gonna do so like the studio bought it
tobe Hooper famously of Texas Chainsaw
Massacre fame was originally supposed to
direct it but then he went off to do
life force so they gave it to Dan
O'Bannon who had been tasked with
rewriting John Russo's screenplay now
what that what Dan O'Bannon wanted to do
was it I guess he didn't want to step on
Romero's dick but he did want to like
reference it so it was kind of in the
same universe so what he ended up doing
was he ended up making the zombies
completely different but he made it and
this is referenced in the movie where
the events of Night of the Living Dead
actually really did happen but when
George Romero made a movie about it he
had to change the details so he wouldn't
get sued you know what I mean so in this
in this like universe the [ __ ] with
visibie is real it's just it was
fictionalized for that movie and
so the return of the Living Dead and the
subsequent sequels are like what really
happened which I thought was a pretty
clever way to let go about it it doesn't
really matter though it all kind of fits
in together anyway it does kinda think
about it I mean you can watch all those
movies side by side and enjoy a ball
yeah I mean now this is definitely the
best one I think I've only seen I saw
part two which is decent it's not you
know as iconic or as fun as this one but
it has its moments
oh yeah it's not as serious as Night of
the Living Dead no not by a long shot
s'more kind of like day of the dead yeah
the very last [ __ ] Romero one day the
dead the weird thing about this one and
one of the things that I really like
about it and one of the reasons why I
think it's still like kind of a popular
cult movie nowadays is because it has
this really like kind of a comedic tone
to it yeah but the story itself is
actually really bleak you know what I
mean so it kind of has that really cool
like 80s you know I don't want to call
it schizophrenic necessarily but it does
have this like a horribly existential
dread type of story but then it's like
as funny [ __ ] going on in it yeah it's
yeah it's kind of like Danah dead meets
meets uh the one with [ __ ] what's the
one I'm thinking of what [ __ ] one
where the guy goes out the house like an
evil did you okay it's kind of has that
net thing kind of that silliness of Evil
Dead yeah do it okay
but I loved Evil Dead yeah and when we
saw Evil Dead when it first came out it
actually kind of scared me I was glad
that it had some it has here en este
tribe that had humour in it because it
wouldn't like petrify you when you
wouldn't when you were you know a
teenager yeah yeah I don't know just
saying it the threshold was different
back then
well I do think I mean definitely Evil
Dead does have some scary parts to it I
feel like Evil Dead is kind of like a
horror movie that has funny parts in it
whereas Evil Dead 2 was just like a
comedy that was just like marginally a
horror movie this one is not scary but
it is like a lot of fun it's super gory
like there's a really lot of cool like
effects and everything so basically what
you got also
I feel like maybe people that are
younger or into zombie movies nowadays
one of the things that this movie was
the first one to do was this is the
first one that made zambese be able to
run some people thought that it was 28
days later but that's not the case it
was 1985 and these were the first
zombies that ran they were also the
first zombies that specifically wanted
to eat human brains they could talk
about a little bit and they could talk
and they were still intelligent and they
were good at problem-solving yeah um so
they didn't actually lose any of their
intelligent like reanimated humans
rather than just like animalistic yeah
sort of zombies like a lot of them did
talk in this one I liked it when I first
saw one of the things that really stood
out was old Lana what's her name Lena
um what's her name Linnea quickly Linnea
quickly a scream queen yeah she's in it
also in Hollywood Chainsaw hookers and
yet already babes in the slimeball
bowl-o-rama and she said he spends half
the time in this movie naked more than
half my bags run around and she's in
peak hotness [ __ ] fur fur for Quigley
she [ __ ] looks really good
I had forgotten until I was watching a
red letter media review of this earlier
and I had forgotten that Linnea Quigley
did a VHS tape of like horror exercise
like a horror workout tape and after
like doing workouts it was like all
these people dressed up like zombies
like it was like oh yeah it totally
forgot about that
because I [ __ ] loved her she was a
trip she was a trip she plays a
character named trash in this yeah punk
rock chick I guess that was this is back
in the time where you know like
liberated women had no problem taking
their clothes off make a living taking
their clothes off well the weird thing
is like one of the other chicks that was
in this the one will like with the blue
hair she was I believe she was actually
a stripper but she didn't like get naked
for this funny but Linnea quigly would
get naked at the drop of a hat she just
did not get it she was known for that
yet so that's yeah like every movie she
is in she spent like half of it naked
yeah she's supposed to be everybody
loved her but evidence she was super
cool I met her a long time ago like at a
horror convention it she seemed like a
lovely human being you know what I mean
um but yeah she's kind of known for like
you know sticking the lipstick in her
boob and [ __ ] sorority babes I'm like
just do
crazy gotta liven up a movie you know
better
she knew what these movies were went
along with it you know I mean that's
she was an attraction well yeah big-time
I mean that's why everybody still
remembers her fondly to every stage
every teenage boy [ __ ] was looking
for that [ __ ] [ __ ] lenny Quigley
[ __ ] movie
yeah and that image that's the thing
when people talk about this movie I
think everybody when he says when you
talk about that scene it's like you know
the one with one a a Quigley dancing
naked on the top of the gravy air it was
on so all right so let's kind of talk
about the sort of plot of this movie
such as such as it is I'm like I said I
really like the fact that they went a
little made-up meta with it in the sense
that like you know the [ __ ] that
happened in Night of the Living Dead was
actually real but they had to change it
you know what I mean
so so that's kind of where they're
coming from so you got your two main
characters who are Frank and Freddie and
Freddie is like a younger guy and he
just gets a job at this medical supply
warehouse it's a place where they you
know they send skeletons and you know
fetuses and then cut in half dogs and
things like that in case you ever need
anything like that I guess some people
do so he's what we start out he's just
got a job there and the older guy Frank
is like training him like showing him
the ropes around the warehouse and
whatnot so as they're like eating lunch
or like you know talking or whatever
he's like hey you ever seen that movie
knighted Living Dead oh that's a real
story and then he says he says
coincidentally that it's like the
military was working on this stuff that
like supposedly reanimated corpses oh
and guess what the reanimated corpses
were accidentally sent here 14 years ago
I think it was 14 years ago and they're
still in the basement you want to see
her of course as you would the dudes
like [ __ ] yeah I want to be that [ __ ] so
[ __ ] yes you also find out in this movie
the zombification also affects animals
that's right it's which that's the first
yeah that's another thing that I think
this might have been the first one to do
that because not only did the little cut
in half dog come to life all the
butterflies that were pinned on the wall
it was just like a second gag but all
the dead butterflies like started
flapping and stuff like that - which I
thought was like a really nice touch
doesn't matter how rotten something is
it still good that was another thing
that they yeah because like some of the
ones that came out of the groups that
come out of the graveyard later on or
just like skeletons cousins of the
eyeballs and there they can still talk
and they can still move around and
everything like that which you know from
a physical standpoint at the end of the
movie big at the end of the movie some
nuclear stuff happens which kind of
makes you think it ties in with David ed
remember how they were down in it yeah
yeah which I guess that might fit in a
timeline maybe yeah it's almost like
it's kind of like a parallel right
universe like I said it's like one
commenting on the other yeah the spirit
of the time you weren't supposed to be
overanalyzing [ __ ] you just watched the
damn movie the dead you didn't worry
about what year certain things happened
in you know what hold on is this 1981
when that's happening or what you know
what's up what when was the other movie
made what year was that supposed to be
happening we didn't think that way back
then well I just well the thing about it
nowadays is that audiences because they
have seen so much and they've consumed
so much media audiences nowadays are a
lot more sophisticated so you can't get
away with just like hand waving stuff
anymore yeah you really have to like be
on your [ __ ] and you have to make sure
everything and make everything to make
sure everything fits together just if it
doesn't someone will call you out on it
Russ second back then it didn't matter
we knew it was just a movie yeah
everyone was just like whatever yes fun
you get to boobs and it's like you get
to see it with zombies eating people and
whatnot but yeah so so what ends up
happening another thing is that this was
kind of like that where this differed
from Romero zombie universe was that you
you know in most Sambi movies it's like
oh you shoot him in the head and they
die in this one you couldn't kill them
which animate in a way makes it scarier
yeah because like so they have so
there's no there's one cadaver like in
this medical warehouse right and you
know when the you know when they
accidentally get you know bust the gas
or two for five trioxin or whatever it's
gone and when it like you know gets out
into the warehouse and the one cadaver
the yellow cadaver comes back to life
the first thing they think of as you
would if Night of the Living Dead
was real and if other zombie movies were
real was that well oh you just like
bashing in the head and I'll die
so Klug Euler dares character I love
that clue Gallagher's in this he's
[ __ ] great but I still remember him
from [ __ ] he was in a movie that was
on Mystery Science Theater I think it
was San Francisco International like
that TV movie about the airport
it had Pernell Roberts in it but yeah so
clue go click Ferris in this too and
he's like the big boss like the owner of
the medical warehouse so they're all
just like well you know get in the head
and they'll die so he sticks the pickaxe
through the [ __ ] head and that
doesn't do anything so then they're just
kind of like okay well cut its head off
so then they cut the head off and that
doesn't do anything either and then they
cut it into pieces and each piece can
move around independently yeah so they
come to the conclusion you know as you
would and even though this is what kind
of like sets off the the much larger you
know zombie outbreak is that well we
have to take it across the street to my
friend who works at the mortuary and put
it in the crematorium and burn it all up
because otherwise it's just gonna keep
it's you know we can't kill it
yeah so they end up going over there and
burning the body that they've already
cut up they burn all the pieces of the
body and the smoke that comes out of the
crematorium goes up into the clouds
causes acid rain and then the acid rain
comes down the cemetery across the
street and wakes up all the zombies yeah
and as I said like all the zombies and
this one are still intelligent and they
are fast and so in a way like I said
it's a funny movie but also if you think
about the implications of it and also
that you can't kill them it makes it
like much scarier because the thing
about it too is that you know when one
of the characters Tina because there's
also you know the punks who were like
waiting there were a friend of Freddy's
and they were waiting across the street
at cemetary like for him to get off work
so they could pick him up and go do
whatever they were gonna do so one of
the girls Tina she's like trying to run
away from the very famous zombie the tar
man who was the one that was originally
in the in the barrel from the Army and
she locks herself in this thing and the
tar man knows enough to get like a winch
and like you know
Chane and like pull the door off the
hinges so these are not like dumb
zombies it'll just sit there and like
paw at the door like while you're in
there and she'll like that they will
figure out how to get your ass and your
brain and that was another thing that
they went into too is that they gave a
reason for why they eat the brains
because they find this one zombie woman
who's just like half of it she's like
all rotten and she's just how like has
her little spines sticking out there and
they actually she kills one of the
character one of the punk characters who
I think his nameis cuz if I'm not over
the top yeah so so she kills cos and
they and they capture her and strap her
to a table and it's a great [ __ ]
effect it's an animatronic and it still
looks [ __ ] fantastic I love that they
had the detail of like her little spine
which is kind of going back and forth
like kind of like Pookie's little stumpy
nose now that I'm thinking about it but
her little spine like goes back and
forth like that and like spinal fluid
drips out the table and stuff I'm like
oh nice touch but yeah so they ask her
it's like what why do you want to eat
people and she's saying she doesn't want
to eat people she wants to eat brains
because that is the only thing that
alleviates the pain of being dead okay
and this made me think that like I said
this is a bleak movie if you think about
it because these zombies that have been
reanimated they can feel what being dead
and rotting feels like I guess the
hunger kind of did a similar thing to
that too because they were still
conscious yeah you know that was
vampires like not zombies but but um
yeah I think what them though wasn't
paying just extreme age yeah I think
that was kind of world I mean they did
like fall apart at that and I guess that
killed them but the thing about this one
is that you know the implication being
that as rotten as you were like her
skeletal as you were anything like that
that you would still be able to feel
that and you know the two characters
Frank and Freddy from the beginning who
were the first ones to like get the full
you know brunt of the you know the
trioxin when it came out of the of the
tank and they like got knocked out and
then they started looking like you know
hammered [ __ ] like when they're walking
they're all pale and like their eyes are
all red and everything and then it
it ends up they just aren't in more and
more pain but it ends up that they are
also dead but they're still walking
around and so they kind of go into they
can feel like the pain of like being
dead because like rigor mortis starts to
set in you get like the blood lividity
like if the pooling and the thing and
and they can feel it because they're
still conscious so that's a pretty
horrible idea and I'm actually like
surprised that another franchise didn't
pick that idea up and run with it
because think how [ __ ] horrified that
would be and like I said - the fact that
- that the zombies are smart and that
they can't be killed by any means
because if you burn them then it goes up
into the atmosphere and spreads at even
far I remember what the scene was like
when this movie came out though the
whole zombie concept was getting kind of
tired it was and this was like the
latest greatest like last one it was
like the last hurrah of the zombie genre
as far as we were concerned yeah we had
no idea the Walking Dead would come out
[ __ ] I mean it was a bit gasoline
like after yeah it was like a big gap
because everyone's kind of sick of
zombies yeah this was kind of you know I
mean so this this is kind of like the
cherry on top they put up this movie and
you weren't gonna see another one and
they didn't make an element not a good
one from yeah this one had I think it
had four sequels I've only seen the
second one which like I said is decent
yeah the genre was not that popular
during that time no people were sick of
it some so much good stuff was coming
down the pipe after this yeah think
about all the [ __ ] great movies that
came after this oh yeah there was a ton
of fun yeah I mean although I will say
like late eighties early 90s there were
like kind of a lot of sequels reanimate
her from beyond the whole reanimate er
series the more stuff from with phantasm
started to come out after this [ __ ] but
can a Hellraiser there was you know
there was a lot of stuff that was coming
out after this that was like better I
guess you could say yeah well people
thought was more interesting cuz it was
it was new yeah you know that's how I
remember it
I remembered like in the movie when I
saw yeah I remember enjoying it when I
first
saw it but I wasn't really it wasn't my
favorite movie yeah you know there was a
lot of other stuff that was a lot better
going on at that time it's just you know
it just was what it was it was a movie
of its time yeah and it and for a while
zombies were kind of coming to an end at
this period I from whatever yeah that's
how I remembered it
you know seeing it well because I mean
George Romero zombie series had
concluded although I think Day of the
Dead came out the same year as this
movie so they almost kind of seemed like
they were you died to the same coin
another thing that the tone of it for
the time it was very familiar it was
kind of a fun and friendly movie it
didn't really stick with you or change
your opinions about things it didn't
really affect you that much when stuff
like stuff like phantasm was kind of
scary kind of spooky what the [ __ ] was
that you know I mean especially phantasm
1 & 2 it was pretty neat yeah just that
would kind of stick with you a little
bit more you know that's just that's
just how I remembered it yeah I mean
this one is definitely much more just
like a fun exploitation ya type of movie
I don't even know if they were if he was
trying necessarily to do a whole other
thing with the zombies um but that is
essentially what happened and I mean
it's funny because like I said I don't
even know because they've done so many
parodies since then of zombies going
around going brains and stuff like that
but that this movie is where that came
from there was no there was nothing like
leading up to that that was just like a
detail that he it's funny how the movie
never really went away yeah you know I
mean I saw the movie and enjoyed it but
it just kept coming back it never really
went away even though you don't I mean I
didn't really think it was that great at
the time but you watch it now and it
does hold up yeah it's like I said it's
a lot of fun and the thing about it is
that I really loved and I was like
watching something else about it today
like some behind the scenes [ __ ] and
apparently what they did was that I mean
there had been like weeks and weeks and
weeks of rehearsals of like all the
actors and stuff so they had gotten very
used to one another and it was almost
kind of like they ran through it like
stage plays and stuff so you can kind of
see how you know a lot of the
characters and the scenes they're all
like talking over each other like
yelling over each other like real people
would in that situation now the [ __ ] is
over-the-top but that's one of the
things that makes it funny is that you
know particularly the characters of you
know Frank and Freddie who are like the
you know the the older guy and the
younger guy who work at the medical
warehouse and you start out everything
the their interaction between each other
it's just so funny because like I said
they do everything that you logically
would do like you know you're confronted
with a corpse that is not up a find it's
like you try to get it in the head just
like the movie says which cracks me up
when Freddie's like you mean the movie
lied because it's like it doesn't work
and it's like okay well now we'll cut
the head off and then we'll cut it up
and then we'll like put it in the oven
and all this other kind of stuff and so
it's it's believable like the you know
the the way that they go about like you
know trying to get rid of this problem
but then they just are slowly I guess
because the situation just keeps getting
worse and worse because they don't
realize that burning that corpse
cause the acid rain that made all the
other you know zombies wake up so
they're just getting like more and more
and more hysterical like as the movie
goes on just because everything's
getting more getting worse and worse and
they don't know what they're gonna do
and then you get all these [ __ ]
zombies it's like and like I said they
do [ __ ] they call the cops they call the
ambulance they call everything like that
but the zombies like overrun like you
know and there's a very funny like
famous scene where one of the zombies
like eats the two paramedics brains and
then calls on the radio for more
paramedics you know what it's like to
send more paramedics more cops so they
have more people to eat it's like you
know the cops come they cordon off the
area but it still doesn't work they're
still like overrun because there's so
many of them you know and subsequently
you know it's it just seems like it's
kind of spreading and there's like so
many that they can't like contain it
anymore and then finally they do like
what maybe they should have done at the
beginning was like call the 1-800 number
that was on the side of the tank like
hey if something bad happens with this
tank maybe you want to call this number
so they finally do that at the end of
the movie like as a last resort and they
they get this guy like in California who
I guess for 14 years has been
standby like waiting for this news
because they didn't know like where
these where these bodies got sent to or
where this stuff got sent to so it's
like now that they know where it is and
they're like well they check out the
situation they're like well the place is
overrun it's Louisville Kentucky it's
that's not where they shot it but that's
where it's supposed to be and they're
like well just nuke it yeah the guys
supposed to be in something that we had
back in then and they were working on it
they planned on - it's called an MX
missile which is a damn train system and
this be a big train system with ducting
nuclear missiles that you can move
around on train tracks so the Soviets
would never know where your where your
missiles were called the MX system they
never made it but they kind of had a
mock-up of what an MX missile system
would look like they used like a model
of a German railgun for World War 2 they
had him in there and he lost a nuclear
missile destroyed but was it Knoxville
it was Louisville though
like I said they shot it in Burbank but
where the where the cemetery was
supposed to be and everything even
though they built that that Cemetery
gate everything like I don't think that
would have worked though well it didn't
work because that's the whole thing you
know that's why they had that whole
thing where when they burned the body in
the crematorium it caused the acid rain
that made the zombies so the implication
is that the nuclear bomb is gonna make
it worse because they burned up all the
zombies it goes up into the atmosphere
and it's grains gonna and it's gonna
wake up zombies all over the place yeah
and a nuclear weapon you know the the
main the main
effective force is that damn shock wave
and that shock wave wouldn't have killed
those zombies not under the print not
under what not under the conditions that
they showed yeah yeah anime cuz if you
couldn't cut him apart hop the shockwave
kill him yeah so yeah I wouldn't work I
don't know why yeah like I said it was
just kind of like they they were just
making the the statement that it's like
it was supposed to be fire that killed
them and then but burning them up spread
the infection yeah even more so really
like I said that's what it that's what I
mean about this being like really bleak
there's not that whole there's not only
that whole you know you can feel like
what it's like being dead and you can
feel yourself rotting and stuff which is
a horrible idea but also there's real I
mean there's really no way to defeat
them because even blowing them up or
burning them is definite
that just makes the problem worse like a
typical 80s horse because you're
spreading it yeah like a typical horror
80s sci-fi movie you know it's not
really that well thought out I mean you
know there's a 1-800 number and the
military knows how to fix the problem
but they don't know how to fix the
problem yeah and that's well I think
that and I mean I'm not sure if this is
what they intended or if they even
thought as much about it as I did but I
thought that had they called that number
at the beginning like before the [ __ ]
really hit the fan then probably they
had some kind of contingency measures to
prevent the outbreak like being like hey
don't burn the [ __ ] cuz it'll spread
even more but since they waited until
the very end to call that number there
was nothing else they could do rather
than just like nuking the [ __ ] it looks
like the only way to top the outbreak is
like what you saw in the beginning of
the movie you'd have to catch them all
and put them into damn drawing drums
that's where they came out yeah which
I'm not sure yeah I'm not even sure like
how they did that originally but it
doesn't matter they don't go into it I
think all they say about now the the
chemical trioxin 2 4 5 trioxin that was
based on it wasn't based on a real so
there's not like a you know drug that
reanimates corpses that we know of
um you know it wouldn't shock me if
there was but it was actually kind of
based on a couple of real chemicals or
like [ __ ] they were working on that was
like experimental but I think they
mentioned in the movie that I think the
chemical wasn't it initially made to
like kill marijuana plants or something
like that from but then it ended up like
reanimated corpses and they were like oh
well is this a feature or a bug we're
not really sure but it did start like
waking up all these corpses at that
that's they put them in the tank and
that's kind of where it's probably
nothing more than roundup yeah that's it
maybe with something like that yeah but
yeah so you know let's there's there's
like such great [ __ ] in this one I have
to say the tar man zombie one of the
best zombies of all time he's [ __ ]
looks great he's all goopy the guy that
was in I can't remember his name but the
guy that was in the like under the suit
or whatever he was an actor and he
worked a lot with Jim Henson like he was
in some of the Muppets and all that kind
of stuff he was like a puppeteer and he
was like really great in this like the
way he moved was really good and also
awesome I want to say what's the deal
with the dude that owns the mortuary
Ernie Kaltenbrunner I think he was
supposed to be based on like a real Nazi
or something like that because he did
have I mean the pistol he had was like
one and he had a picture of Eva Braun
right like yeah David brought up right
if it's a Hitler incident uh German yeah
socialist military music I guess he was
supposed to be an ex Nazi I guess yeah
it's like it was just that was one of
the funniest things didn't he didn't
look like one that's what I mean it's
like but that was one of the funniest
things to me is that they put all that
in there but then they nobody brings it
up and like nobody and he's not like
outwardly Nazi ish or anything he's like
he seems like an okay dude and so I just
thought it was kind of funny that they
just like made those references think
I'd ever want a 70 I think it was
supposed to be something kinda like dr.
Strangelove yeah maybe that's kind of
where they were things where they were
coming from yeah um also can I say that
the soundtrack for this is [ __ ] great
I love the soundtrack for this it had
like a lot of you know you had 45 grave
you had T Sol the Damned the cramps you
know the last one was the cramps but
it's like I feel like this this movie
some [ __ ] ended up happening with it
later on where I guess there's been like
copyright issues with like some of the
songs in there so I think that some of
the subsequent re-releases like on
blu-ray and stuff they had to like swap
out certain songs because they couldn't
get the rights to them I think the
damned one in particular there was some
issue with the rights and they had to
like put a different song in there like
in later iterations and also there was
also an issue with some of the audio
where because I think that the tar man
when he says you know brains and
everything like that I don't know if
that's that dudes actual voice or if
that's the original audio for that voice
I think they dubbed it over later and
I'm not even really sure if the original
version still exists I think the last
blu-ray that came out like the kind of
big special edition was in 2016 and I'm
assuming because they only just now put
this on shutter I'm assuming that that's
like that 2016 version is the
version that they're using but I don't
know I mean I'm pretty sure that that's
not the original audio and to be honest
I don't remember hearing the Damned in
that in that movie I can't remember what
the original soundtrack was I don't
either because like I said I saw just
yeah I saw this in like the mid to late
80s at some point I'm surprised that the
movie has held up as well as it did and
it's still around it was a movie that
just kept reappearing over and over
again video rental places and that's
people [ __ ] show it at parties and
certain songs would end up certain songs
off the track would end up in [ __ ]
dance clubs like [ __ ] Man Ray and
stuff it was just a movie that never
really went away I was kind of surprised
about it because it was good in those
days when I saw it but it didn't really
seem to be that special yeah at the time
at the time it didn't yeah no no but
looking at it now I can see why I made
it stuck out because it did something
really interesting and different with
the zombie thing and like I said a lot
of the [ __ ] that they came up with I
don't even know if they were trying to
be like all different on purpose but
just like I said he didn't want to go
the same way as the Romero zombies he
wanted to like homage the Romero movies
but not yeah you know but not like copy
that or not I remember at the time
seeing it I didn't feel that that's what
it was yeah I felt it was more like a
ripoff that's how I saw it at the time I
didn't know it had the same people
involved in it yeah it initially was
supposed to be a straight sequel but you
know this was pre-internet you couldn't
check on anything you really didn't keep
track of these names I mean they were
contemporary for the time they weren't
legendary back then these people then
became that way over time and during
those days you didn't know who they were
they were just movies and that showed up
your damn local rental store some of the
people you'd remember and a lot of
people you wouldn't you know yeah like I
said I do feel like I mean ever I'm has
helped this [ __ ] become classic it
wasn't that classic that it wasn't
classic fan well there was so much of it
comes out gen2 and it's like so a lot of
it was bad yeah gone you forgot about it
it's [ __ ] vanished well that's why
it's easier to appreciate you know stuff
like in hindsight in retrospect because
you have you know you you've had time to
like
flecked on it all the bad [ __ ] that came
out you know that year whatever
everybody just forgot about it and you
know only the good [ __ ] like stays
around it gets remembered for whatever
reason so I think that's I think that's
another thing to wear
you know how older people always be like
oh they don't make good music anymore oh
they don't make good movies anymore
there's like that bad [ __ ] but yeah it's
it's only because we just remember the
good [ __ ] from back is I mean 1985 there
was a [ __ ] ton of terrible movies that
came out of 1985 it's just that nobody
remembers them the only ones you
remember are the good ones
it was because it was the beginning of
the video rental store yeah and when you
were a kid you had money to go down
there to [ __ ] you know your parents
are here who you think [ __ ] give you
money to [ __ ] get you out of there
yeah you had an allowance so we would
[ __ ] take our allowances and go down
and go rent movies it might be three or
four of us you know read movies and
watch them together and so we might have
six movies but a teenage boys can watch
six movies over over a week teenage
girls can't you know yeah just watch it
yeah you got enough snacks yeah yeah it
doesn't seem boring and it doesn't you
know I mean it's especially back then
because you had the energy and
everything was fun back then even boring
[ __ ] so we wouldn't so you know they
made a whole industry of there had to be
a big supply of movies at any one time
because guys were renting them yes
you're burning through that just burning
through this watch three I'm a [ __ ]
night well a lot of them were bombs and
yeah a lot of them were terrible you
didn't know what it was you just rented
it based upon the the title of it and
what the cover looked like yeah some of
that [ __ ] was just terrible terrible the
covers were way better than the men yeah
you said cover that up but that would be
good and then you take it back there and
you're like oh hey this [ __ ] sucks
sometimes they were so bad they were
good sometimes they weren't sometimes
they were just boring you could like I
can't get through this and we just
change it yeah and it's kind of a bummer
because sometimes I mean I used to go in
there and [ __ ] love the covers for
like microwave massacre and stuff like
that but then like you'd rent it you'll
be like well that wasn't as cool as I
was okay yeah they're like fake versions
of the Terminator yeah fake Robocop
movies those are [ __ ] terrible a lot
of a big alien yeah lots of fake like I
said they still like on Mystery Science
Theater
RiffTrax always if you watch Brandon 10
olds Channel it's like they've done a
[ __ ] ton of just like crappy knockoff or
[ __ ] case cinema um you know I'm just
crappy knockoff 80s [ __ ] because it was
a dude on a ton a [ __ ] knock option
what was funny is that sometimes the
knockoffs would be good like there was a
sometimes there was a good alien
knockoff called galaxy of terror yeah
that was Roger Corman and it turned out
to be Roger Corman but nobody knew who
he was when that movie came out but that
movie looked really good it had sig egg
sid haig in it yeah it had the girl from
i had the girl from [ __ ] Brady Bunch
in it the girl gets [ __ ] ready but
she was from happy days that's right hey
have some hot chick she gets raped by a
gigantic [ __ ] worm man hey whoa yeah
yeah it's just [ __ ] the teenage boy want
to see although gal I mean Roger Corman
was a pretty big name by jeez because I
mean because he had made all this really
cool extra info adaptations and when we
read it we didn't know who Roger Corman
was yeah okay had we known who robbed
your Corman was we wouldn't have rented
it yeah because it's like he did shitty
movies mostly okay but the special
effects were done by the do too did
alien and Terminator what was his name
[ __ ] you just he mentioned his name
which one James Cameron or James Cameron
well he'd if some of them did some of
the special effects in that movie yeah
and it looked like some of it looked
like stuff out of alien to that movie
was punching way above its weight I have
yes a galaxy of terror it ends like [ __ ]
just got terrible end I mean Roger
Corman's kind of hit or miss like I said
I loved his Edgar Allan Poe adaptations
um but he did some really like knockoff
like I mean cuz but you gotta give the
dude props he never lost money on a
movie and he had a career since the [ __ ]
in 1950s man there was a bunch of fake
Star Wars movies you know battle beyond
the stars and [ __ ] like that star crash
star crash that's the probably the best
Italian Star Wars as [ __ ] but you know
it never forgot it
and then there was [ __ ] fake there
was fake Mad Max like [ __ ] metal
storm number metal storm and [ __ ] and
in the Forbidden Zone it was a ton of
Mad Max yeah like I said they did they
did some of them on MST there was one
called warrior the lost world or
something like that the same thing like
a wasteland yeah whatever and it's like
they said that was like a whole that's
like a whole was [ __ ] genre at this
point I remember like in [ __ ] metal
storm it was supposedly it supposed to
be in 3d it had [ __ ] cyborgs and it
all kinds of crazy and then like what
was it called something hunter
adventures in the Forbidden Zone it had
Molly Ringwald in it that was I remember
I remember liking that one and [ __ ] for
some reason I wanted to say but no I
think it might have been space Holly
yeah adventures in the Forbidden Zone
well [ __ ] now I gotta look that up and
see what the deal what that is I
remember kind of liking it yeah I
haven't seen in a long time but back in
those days I liked it yeah yeah but yeah
so definitely like I said if you're into
zombie movies and you're just kind of
like and you want to see something that
you know was was done different with the
genre like because so many people took
like Romero's [ __ ] and ran with it
which you know that's fine but even [ __ ]
like The Walking Dead and stuff like
that are still oh moshing Romero but
this one you know kind of went a
different direction with it and like I
said I'm surprised that a lot of the
[ __ ] that they came up with in this
movie didn't get used more like I'm
surprised this didn't like spawn its
whole like zombie offshoot type of
movies with the die me the timing wasn't
right I guess not well like you said it
was kind of getting to be enough I mean
you know like I said this is the same
year that day the dead came out and
really it goddamn it it's like now I'm
trying to remember like in the late 80s
if there were any like really big like
popular zombie movies but maybe not like
I feel like the zombie thing didn't
really get kicked back off again until
like the early 2000s maybe like with 28
days later and and that also had fast
zombies and a lot of people bitched
about that but returned the Living Dead
was the first one to do it
first one to do fat to first want to do
fast zombies first wanted to
brain-eating zombies and as far as I
know one of the only ones until Romero's
started to go oh the zombies are
involving intelligence to make the
zombies like just as intelligent as a
human [ __ ] all that they needed they
need to redo
Mega Man and they got to do a Megaman
right what did that have to do with
anything I'm just saying he's just this
[ __ ] just I'm just saying that they
haven't that they've done all this fake
stuff and remakes it but they haven't
they did I am Legend which was fake
Omega Man it's from this I wish somebody
with me one that was it like in the book
yeah well I think I think that what they
did in Omega Man with Charlton Heston is
actually the way to go that that movie
would have been perfect if there was
more action especially at the end yeah
but that was they need to redo that with
the talking mutants and everything well
yeah like I said it would be good to do
that or like I said you barring that to
do something closer to the book because
honestly they've made three adaptations
of that book and none of them are that
close to the milk last man on earth with
Vincent Price is probably the closest
but not but all of them kind of change
it yeah you couldn't do that movie would
be slow about a date standards no no
maybe I don't know I always really liked
that one I mean oh me I like a Mega Man
but they kind of did its own he did is
it yeah that post-apocalyptic way is the
way to go I mean I am Legend the Will
Smith one that was just terrible because
I mean the whole ending of they they
[ __ ] whiffed the whole ending they
with the whole concept yeah it's like
it's not even anything it's like they
took the whole [ __ ] point of the book
and just like [ __ ] all over there's
supposed to be the last man on earth
you're the last one that everybody else
is of either a vampire or some kind of a
mutant well you know I mean you're
trying to survive many that's how it's
supposed to be you're the monster yeah
well yeah that was the whole point of
the book the vampires vampires are
scared here means that they were scared
of you yeah and that was like the irony
that was the [ __ ] point of the book
did anybody get they kind of did that it
did that in Heston's a Mega Man they did
a bit it was crazy in the end the
mutants were thought he was an
abomination and they were trying to get
an abomination from the past they're
trying to get rid of it yes kind of go a
little bit in that direction yeah but I
do feel like when they did I am Legend
even though they named it the same thing
as the book and that's the whole point
of that [ __ ]
name of the book is that you are like
the boogeyman like from their point of
view even though you think they're the
boogeyman so they named it the same
thing but then they just totally went to
an opposite - like what the [ __ ]
wanted of us I don't know I didn't
understand it I don't say this is why
I'm not a screenwriter I guess but yeah
so like I said Return of the Living Dead
it might be on to be for free I'm not
entirely sure but um because I was
actually planning on reviewing this
anyway because I was pretty sure that I
saw it on TV for free but then like a
day or two before we were gonna record
this shudder added it along with a bunch
of other 80s classic eighties slashers
including sleepaway camp and several of
its sequels and they just added the
burning which one of the kind of an
underrated slasher had a lot of Tom
Savini special effects maybe we'll want
to review that sometime later this month
because I I really like that movie as
well so yeah go to shudder and check it
out if you haven't seen it like I said
if you like zombies got some great gore
it's very funny and it's got like a
really kick-ass punk-rock soundtrack if
you're into that kind of thing